[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Волинь,
Луцьк]
Пам'ятник — це є не тільки архітектура малих форм,
але також це є своєрідна філософія.
Тим паче, я їх багато робив.
Я з пам'ятниками дуже пов'язаний ще з молодості.
Ця пластика надзвичайно мені близька.
[Микола Головань
Архітектор, скульптор]
Я в різних, можна сказати,
психологічних ситуаціях їх робив.
Я пройшов Львівську академію.
Мої батьки дуже хотіли,
щоб я став художником.
Коли я у свої 16-17 років вступив до Львова.
Було таке училище імені Труша.
Я й училище закінчив, й академію закінчив.
Це 1960-ті, 1970-ті роки.
Якщо є вдалі пам'ятники — це даються
якісь думки для переосмислення.
Як скульптор, я хочу висловити емоції,
аби людина не заходила у глухий кут.
Я зробив купідона.
Тут також буде невеличкий фонтан.
Тут багато різних пластичних елементів.
Деякі моменти цього подвір'я,
екстер'єру є більш-менш завершеними.
Деяким ще далеко до завершення.
Доводиться не 7 разів подумати, а 10,
щоб знайти кожній деталі своє місце.
І я знаходжу певні місця, що бачу:
саме там є робота.
Чимало накопичилося тут за останні роки.
Проте я стараюся усьому знайти своє місце.
Мені пощастило вчитися у Львові.
Я мав прекрасних викладачів.
Мав прекрасну можливість
бачити ландшафт будинків та їхню пластику.
Мав чудові можливості
величного міста Західної України.
І можливо, саме ці обставини підштовхнули мене
до будівництва цього будинка, цього «Вернісажу».
Цей «Вернісаж» діє.
Він заохочує до діалогу.
Я радію, коли приходять екскурсії.
Гарні люди з ближчих та віддаленіших країн.
Що для мене було важливо?
Передусім, як і для кожного,
має бути будинок, де він живе.
А яка ідея?
Творити, тому що так мене вчили.
Якби я того не робив, то я творив би абидесь.
А де я творив би?
У підвалах?
То не діло.
А тут — це ж велика справа.
Ви знаєте, мене часом дратує:
«Коли то Ви все закінчите?».
Ну що таке «закінчите»?
Складається вражеення, ніби я якийсь обиватель.
Паркан побудував, те зробив,
там — 5 кімнат.
І все сяє.
Я це втілював.
Так, водночас мені хочеться,
аби було затишно.
Мені хочеться, аби було привабливо.
Але кожен живе по-своєму.
Я багато малював, але і
вантажником доводилося працювати.
Однак я старався сильно не
віддалятися.
Коли був студентом, мене вербували.
Я працював у Криму простим робочим.
Але я надсилав свої малюнки до редакції.
Друкували.
Просто вирішив спробувати іншого життя.
Ліворуч — дітки, праворуч — дружина,
а я — посередині.
Я ніби Атлант тримаю на собі то.
Я професійно займався спортом.
Мав чудову фізичну підготовку.
Мав багато сили.
Мені була під силу вага будь-якої каменюки.
Ось тут я роблю дворик пам'яті сина.
Це є Nickolas Memorialis.
Це є дворик його робіт.
Це був особливий у мене син.
Він прожив недовгий період, 32.5 роки.
Був різносторонньою,
талановитою та багатогранною особистістю.
Він був ковалем, а також скульптором.
Любив музику та багато малював.
Він залишив багато робіт за своє коротке життя.
Але найголовніше — він залишив мені онука,
якому 20 років.
Онук якнайкраще перейняв
працездатність від мене, як від діда.
Він приходить, допомагає.
Навчається на четвертому курсі.
Я сподіваюсь, що це продовження буде
за нашим прізвищем Голованів.
Якщо я зупинюся, як казав мій батько,
то почуватимуся відділеним від того життя.
У мене було багато щасливих моментів.
Також були й вистраждані
та трагічні.
Я вже не можу ходити так.
Тут я зараз на старому місці.
У нас є чудова річка.
Я купаюся.
Руки працюють і голова працює
у повному розумінні просторового мислення.
Я не згубив здорового глузду,
відчуття певного бачення
здорового змісту того життя.
Хочеться ще створити найчистіше,
що можу тільки утілити як майстер.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Олег Сологуб]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Монтажер
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]